We are back live.
Hi. Here's the plan. I'm be all day
minus minus breakfast in an hour.
Um, we want to get pretty dang close to
the release today. I think we can start
running almost some of the final
experiments.
pretty close to final
experiments and
um generally looking at the remaining
items that need to be done before
release. The fact that neural MMO is
just not learning stuff is a little
weird.
this? I mean, this is a really good one,
right?
I mean, our sweep code definitely works.
I think neural MMO is just
I mean to be fair there are like a lot
of small things we can just like start
doing one by
those? Those would be like two pretty
different M's,
right? Or do we want to see if we can
get mini batch size actually sweepable?
That might be
better. Let's just like let's just start
doing like a few things on this. Playing
around with
And I have some like custom coefficients
on here. It looks
like that pushes it over 3 mil like
immediately.
Oh, it's just going to keep getting
faster,
huh? Okay,
let's let's fix
um the speed reporting so I can actually
see what's going on.
If we ship like 5 mil SPS train demo,
that would be pretty
cool. Even know if that's feasible.
We'll see.
What did I do that would have messed
this up?
I guess like the fact that this is time
based
want to append.
No, we want to do like
Okay, whatever. We'll leave it like this
for now. We'll see if we can come up
with something better after, but this is
decent. So, how does BPT Horizon work
now in the latest
correct. What change that I am allowed
to do
this? Can I just keep making this
larger?
this? Like, does this actually just
work?
4.3. Okay. But you kind of saturate the
games like before then, right?
I mean, what would this be? Just like
way bigger learning
Yeah. I mean, it's cool to see though
that we can actually
like we can actually play with this
variable now.
I don't actually know what
changed before. You know in the earlier
code when I would do this you would get
a diminishing returns like it would go
negative after some
point I guess. Why don't we try to
like why don't we see if we can like max
perf on neural MMO uh on neural MMO then
Okay.
So, this box that I'm using
here is uh sitting on the shelf behind
me,
right? You can see it right there above
my
thumb. This is a pretty nice config. I
wish I'd gotten more of these, but uh
they're on tariffs
Okay. So, this was just not sweeping
mini batch size.
nice. You could say I've been doing some
refactoring on
Okay, let's just um let's have a little
bit of fun until breakfast and figure
out what is the like ludicrously fastest
we can get stuff to train with puffer
now. So, out of the box, we're close to
three mil steps per second with default
settings.
this. Holy
hell. Over 5 mil SPS training.
Now, it doesn't learn anything with
these settings, and I have no idea if
it's even possible to learn anything
with settings that look like
Does that imply like way more
environments would be
better cuz like the way that this works
right it's mini batch divide by total
agents. So the way like I generally set
this up it's
524 288 divide by
uh 81
92 agents is 64
horizon. So then like
131072ide by
64. It's actually only a 2048 batched
board pass. I
guess let's see if I can get the N to
bottleneck it by messing with these
settings a little bit. So like
size. Wait, what do I need to multiply
this by? I think just
um this will satisfy
it.
290. Yeah, this
one. All right. All right. And now I
have to multiply this
by
Oh, because the Hang on. That's because
the BPD horizon though. I did
I I mess up something.
workers. Actually, it's a
16 like this.
So we get hit by like massive copy
overhead,
huh? I mean there are two things that
are a little weird here, right? One is
that the M is way faster than this. The
M should be running at like tens of
millions per second. It shouldn't be
this like really any amount of the
compute. And the second is the copy
overhead shouldn't be that high
um Okay, this is
literally like almost two
terabytes. So then why is this are these
like
Is this like copy overhead or something?
Like
what? What is
this? Let's go look at some things
here. First of all, let's like try to
get this into a state
where we expect this to do something.
more reasonable. So
9% massive number of M's
here. I was going for 32. Can you check
out my sweep? Yes, Spencer. I am uh I'm
trying to see if we can hit like some
ludicrous speedrun on on Breakout. But
yeah, I can totally check out sweeps.
Just link them in the Discord.
I think I should kill the run and
switch. Let me
look. Getting collision below
1%. Is this with
immunity? Okay. So, this Prito run is
not
like like you're getting all the perk
very quickly. Here, we'll do a little
live analysis.
It'll be good for you and for folks
watching so you can see how I look at
these
Um, this ended up actually being a
pretty
good length here. Is this Wait, is this
mil? This is 100 million steps at the
high end,
right? Oh, 150
mil.
Okay. I mean, but you're really you're
getting capped out PF in literally like
no steps at all here.
Um, so I mean that suggests that it's
not just like I don't know why a
kneeling would help you then because you
still have plenty you have plenty
learning right here. You have a few
unstable runs which is
interesting. It improves slowly. Does
it? That looks flat to me at the
top. So this is on log scale and it's
still flat at the top.
You
see, unless there's some in here that
are like, but the best ones seem
The one annoying thing here is just
these plots are not going to be fun for
um because these are like percentages.
It's really tough to do analysis on
scores that have like percentages like
this. You can't really do a ton about
that. That's kind of
um a Neptune problem, but like you have
to kind of like know what difference
actually matters when you get up here. I
mean, these are
actually these are still not to 99. You
can still kind of look at the relative
differences
95. Well, this seems pretty good, right?
There's like a little bit of a curve to
this with the vehicle
collision. So, this seems to have an
effect. Maybe a small one, right? Like
this. This looks like a pretty
consistent line here.
collision. If there is an effect, it's
less because yeah, we've got 0.95 and
0.948. So, this doesn't seem like it
actually matters anywhere near as much
as like over here.
0.95
93 93. Yeah. So, there's like this does
something.
completion rate is not is completion
rate not
score. The point of having the score
variable or I guess the perf variable
now either of those is that it should be
the metric that you care about when you
plot stuff so that regardless of what
experiments you're running you can apply
those plots and you'll actually get the
plots you care
about. Well, do any of these have
completion rate plotted or no?
If this is the metric that you care
about, then this should be the y axis
for
everything,
right? Score is more important than
completion. Okay. Well, then if this is
the metric we care
Well, high value function coefficients
consistent with what I've seen.
I'm arguing over like 3%
here. Well, but like you're not arguing
over 3%. Like 3 percentage points from
51 to 54 is very different from 3
percentage points from like 97 to 100,
right? Like if you look at relative
improvement or relative error
reduction like 99.9 is 10 times better
than 99.
get Wait, why do you think it should be
better without a kneeling?
I have had runs that had episode return
greater than
eight. Have you had runs like on this
version that have done that?
This seems hardbound at eight. Like what
does eight signify? Is there like a
significance to the number
eight? It just happens to
be. Oh man, that there looks like
there's a significance to the number
eight when I'm seeing 9 like 9 7.991 and
nothing is above eight. Oh, I guess
there's an
8.0027
here. Okay, so it's not impossible to
get above
eight, but that's like suspiciously
close to a whole number
boundary for that like to signify
something, you know?
5% vehicle collision. Okay, we can look
at
though. Completion is basically 100 and
off-road
is.3, but like this collision stuff
could still be from things. I guess it
can't be from respawning anymore,
right? Cuz that's no longer a thing.
here. Let me stop making you type
stuff if you're not in
uh if this is easier.
Yep.
Hey. All right. All right. So basically
my assumption and this you this could be
wrong is that if you have like a small
enough learning rate
or that of which I've seen in the
experiments on the analing ones like
it's still making like tiny tiny
improvements on one of the configs on
one like the parameter sets I had
yesterday but you know then it just dies
because I only said it's like 100
million steps right? So yeah. So why
don't you go longer with the kneeling
on?
Well, I I could. I mean, then it's just
a matter of like do I just set like a
fixed point further down the road? Like
set like a fixed like 300 million in
reweep that would
Oh, I see what you mean. Yeah, you would
just set a a longer a log a longer max
and it would have to figure out the
analing coefficient
because I mean at this point now there's
like a ton of parameters, right? So it's
hard for me to kind of gauge like if
it's actually
explored tail end our sweep stuff is
pretty damn good at this point I will
say like it's not perfect but the sweep
algorithm is pretty damn good at finding
hypers um and you do understand how a
kneeling works right like I mean it just
slowly reduces the the learning rate but
do you like understand how much of a
difference that
makes like where is this trapezoidal
LR this
Okay. So
like so this is cosine and he kneeling.
Okay. Yeah. And then this is like this
trapezoidal thing which is like this
other one that they introduced. So the
point is that it has like this cool down
here. Mhm.
Okay. Look at what a difference this
makes in the
graphs. So this is the annealed portion
right here in the loss.
Okay. So like your curves are going to
be smooth with cosine. So you can't
really appreciate how much the annealing
is doing. But like literally just like
pulling down the learning rate at the
end. This is how much better you do
versus having one fixed learning rate.
And this graph is going is the y-axis
going lower good or bad? Good. Okay. So
this is like language model stuff. I I
guess the thing is you weren't around
when like
um
Like let's
see, you probably weren't around to like
see the early like reduce learning rate
on plateau or whatever graphs, but
basically we used to have graphs in ML
that would look like this and they would
like be like saw tooth or whatever
because you would reduce the learning
rate like several times throughout
training. Mhm. So like reducing the
learning rate makes it learn
way faster uh in certain cases. So like
you don't see it because cosine is a
smooth schedule. Um and so is like
linear. But like yeah it I don't think
just disabling like you could just break
stuff basically by turning a kneeling
off. It's worth trying once in a while
because like yeah sometimes m just they
work like that whatever. But uh often
it's like yeah you want to keep a
kneeling and then just have it be able
to run for longer. And that's like one
of the things we discovered with
breakout right like anal like without a
kneeling we totally broke it. Yeah. I
mean that was something for breakout. Uh
but like for neural MMO, don't you do a
linear learning rate for like two
billion steps? Well, why do I do that
though, right? I do that because the
full
run is a 100
bill. So like me analing over two
billion, I do it so that if I Okay, I
guess here's the one thing I do. If I'm
going to do a like a sweep run and then
I'm going to do like a 50x longer run
afterwards, then yeah, you can disable a
kneeling because it's a better chance
that the hyperparameters will
transfer. Is that what you were going
for?
I mean, I assume that when you're going
from a linear learning, no mean just a
flat a fixed learning rate versus using
co using some form of a kneeling that
you have to have entirely different
parameter sets.
Um possibly the main thing is
like usually you do it on there are a
few variables you usually do it on Jason
but yes um so like the reason I do it
and I think that I think we're getting
at the same thing here I can't quite
tell so like let's say that you're going
to run some experiments uh and you just
want the best performance right uh and
higher is better so like and then you
anneal Right? Then you'll get something
that's like this and like this, right?
You get your curves or whatever. And
then but the thing is like if you keep
running these, these are already at like
zero learning rate here,
right? So like you can just set them
longer and you can like hope that you do
this or whatever, but like it's not
really guaranteed because the analing is
kind of a different factor, right? Which
actually to be fair, this is actually
the reason that this thing
exists because you can just keep
extending it and then just at the end is
when it it cools
down. Um,
but the annoying thing about this is
that you have to wait all the way for
the end of training to see if your
experiment's any good, right? Isn't
there something to say about a kneeling?
If like so say right now like right like
it's basically getting to like its peak
performance within like effectively you
know anywhere from 50 to 70 million
steps right now right
um is there not an argument that like
the time of which it is at a certain
learning rate it could learn better if
it was exposed to that learning rate for
an extended period of time versus
continuously dropping through that. So
this is that right? So this is a
constant learning rate. So this is a
warm-up which we're not doing warm-ups
at the moment so ignore that. Um this is
constant learning rate and then it drops
it at the
end. And this is the difference right
like this is how these the curves tend
to look when you do this.
Okay. So like cosine actually it does
better when you tune and anneal the
learning rate typically. But then when
you do the cool down at the end you
actually match like the graphs pretty
well match. to pretty much the same
thing at the end of the day. So
basically like it doesn't seem like
there's really a huge amount of magic in
here like that these two totally
different methods do the same. It's just
like experimental
um convenience with like you know do you
want to be able to have the same
learning rate so you can just run it for
way longer and see if it just keeps
going but then you have to wait for the
very end versus with cosine you probably
have to retune a little more but at
least you get the experimental results
like as they happen you get the cleaner
curves. So given the current setup, is
there not an argument for saying that?
Okay, right now I think my cap is 200,
but I think it never even tried that. I
think it stopped at like 150 as the high
for whatever reason. Well, it stops when
it can't make progress, right?
It has to have a optimal point, right?
Is that like a guaranteed assumption
though? Because like could you not have
a set of parameters at like the 500
million step range that are so
dramatically superior? If it can't make
if it can't do any better with 150
versus like 100, there's not going to be
a PTO optimal point at 150. So it'll
just keep sampling around 100. The way
it does it, it only expands to longer
runs when it gets when it finds a run
that does better than a previous shorter
run.
Okay, sure. Following that
logic, that depends on the luck of the
parameters chosen on the longer run,
right? Like if you if you happen to not
find a good one, you're going to be
stuck in like a shorter time step land.
Well, not entirely until you find it
suggests a big a better one, right? But
like what it does, right? Like let's say
that you like you run some experiments
and this is like time and this is like
you know score. Sure. Sure. Then like
you get you tend to get like stuff that
looks like this, right? And let's say
that this is your best point. Then what
it does is it looks for any it's going
to look like between roughly like here
and here as the max
around this point. I mean technically
what it can uh what it like it can do is
it the way that the algorithm actually
works is it picks a time interval from
like here to
here and then it's going to pick a
point like at it's going to try to pick
a point that it thinks is going to take
this much time. So like it could pick
one here and then it's going to get a
whole bunch of candidate points and
it'll pick whatever it thinks is the
best point. So like it's going to try to
put points over here some fraction of
the time. But if it can't do better than
this point, it's not going to waste the
compute.
But like it's generating a ton of
different candidates and using
predictive models to score like what it
thinks the best point is over here.
All right. So going back to my setup of
the latest run
would the proper analysis be of it okay
it's just capped performance and it's
now down to like bug in data set or some
type of like map related issue well I
mean I can't say for sure there are many
things it could be um some things that
you could do to test it right you could
pick the best set of parameters uh just
increase the model size, maybe fiddle
with the learning rate a little bit and
see if you get anything that like breaks
past. It seems hard stuck at eight,
which is suspicious to me. It would seem
like there's some significance to the
value of eight.
Um, let's see. You can definitely
run Well, yeah, longer sweep is it's not
finding anything, right? So it's just
like not
and I only suspicious because I have the
the current set of params that are in
the release branch that I have which
honestly I think may even be I don't
remember if one of your sets or a set I
found on a different suite but anyways
um one run on a short round of like 80
million everything else stays the same
gets you know still 99 completion rate,
like basically zero off-road rate, and
then anywhere in the range of like 4%
vehicle
collision. When I pump it to like 150
million on the same steps, it seemed as
if it went down to like
3.3, giving me hope that like there is
there does exist some form of parameters
that could get it down to like one or
you know, below one if you just either
continue extending it some way somehow.
collision rate or clean collision rate.
Clean collision rate.
So on this version, the sweep did not
discover it. Like the sweep did not
discover something that aligned with
that particular one I just did on my
computer.
What is this one right here? I Neptune's
really got to make it Oh, here. Yes, it
did.
0.27. 0.027. It also sacrificed other
parameters to get
there on that run.
So, if you find that run and you click
into I don't remember. Let me see if I
can just find the number of that run.
2059,
95% score.
Yeah. And then if you go to off-road
rate, you'll see this is actually higher
than the majority of the other ones.
Hold up. Is it off road? No. Something
was funky with this one. Is it
completion rate?
97.8. Yeah,
it has not gone to 99 like the other
ones. Um, well, what are the
coefficients on the rewards? I
wonder. It's probably just down to that.
I mean, it's playing scared. It's
probably playing scared, right?
Sure. And like that's the only one that
was able to get basically
sub3 collision rate
and the collision rate that's not
including the it's not just because the
spawn immunity timer is really high,
right? It's like Yeah. So there's two
things. Clean collision rate will always
be first
life. So irrelevant of the timer. The
collision
rate collision rate basically equals
clean collision rate at a very high
spawn immunity timer. The lower spawn
immunity timer is collision rate
diverges from clean collision rate to be
higher because of the situation where
you spawn into other cars.
So like yeah I mean this thing it just
must be it must just be playing scared
right? Mhm.
Which is like now for the purposes of
like moving forward at what point do we
say that these quote 72 maps are solved?
because you know it's possible one of
these maps is just so out of
distribution from the other maps that
it's difficult for it to solve relative
to its learning if you were to do 100
maps or 10,000 maps or whatever. Well, I
would think it's definitely worth
getting more maps in because we're going
to want to do that anyways and it'll be
better for experiments. like the just
the padding thing that I would suggest,
right, that I suggested um would let you
load random maps per worker, which would
already give you a bunch.
Okay, so let's talk through that one
because conceptually I had a hard time
trying to think about implementing it.
Mhm.
Um you're going off picking number of
agents, which let's just assume 4096,
right?
Mhm. If you have 496 agents and you want
to make it pretty dynamic on your map
choice, whether you're choosing one map
or 4,96 maps, you just randomly select
maps until you get close to that.
So, you randomly select maps as with in
your innit and resampling, right?
Because you have to recalculate your
agent offsets within that thing. Well,
if you reample, so that's the thing
where they like they switch the maps
every so often and it's kind of slow.
Um, okay. We're going to do that, but I
wouldn't even say bother doing it just
yet. Just like initially, can we at
least get each worker to have
independent maps because we have 16
workers or eight workers, whatever it
is, and like they're all on the same
maps right now,
right? Yeah. Okay. So, you're saying
each worker to have because each worker
picks a random set so them to have
different ones.
Um, okay. Talking let's talk about
padding then. you you know you padding
it's it should be the opposite. It would
be do you you pick maps until you go you
go over, right? Yeah, you go over and
then you just drop the last few cars,
whatever, so that you have exactly 4096
uh in the
obs, but that's not anything to do with
the actual.h file, right? because you're
just cutting off the edge of it and
you're just saying, "Okay, this is now
the end of the offset and it's just
going to Yep. I guess that's a little
awkward, but it it's a tiny bit awkward,
but not really, right?
I guess some cars are going
to get no actions. Yeah, some cars are
just going to park in the middle of the
road. Or you could remove them, which
would be better.
Okay, so there will be I guess possibly
a little bit of logic. How is that going
to get passed in? Uh I guess from
actions, right? I could go based off the
shape of actions and then cut off
anything past.
Well, you don't have shapes in the in
the uh the C. It would be well you can
have the length though because you
you're gonna have you're going to be
given an array of actions.
Uh the C is just a pointer.
You still have the number you still know
the number of cars and stuff total,
right?
There's no reason why you wouldn't know
the total number of cars. Remember you
also can pass stuff to the init function
of binding.
But like you can just pass numb you can
pass numbum cars, right? And just like
on the last one you can just like cut
the max lower.
I mean technically there's no reason you
can't load you can load any of these
maps with any number of the cars from
like zero to however many they actually
have, right?
There's a little bit of funkiness in
that,
[Music]
but should generally be doable because
if you're lowering it from inside of one
of the init functions
after the fact
doesn't have to be after the fact.
I think I'd rather find a way to do it
inside of step
somehow.
Um, like maybe if you don't get an
action for a cards out like if you
override the active agent count variable
via the binding.
Mhm. I mean, whatever way makes sense
with it, but like know you have the M
binding now and you have debugging that
runs through Python. So
okay but we're and okay so but in the
condition
of less maps than total agent count Mhm.
or I guess in this case that's our num
m's
Yeah or max or whatever it is. Yeah.
Whatever the right mathematical
operation is to get a unique number that
fits in the that's divisible or
whatever. Yep.
And no resampling. So each round will
continuously just replay the level it's
given on that set of
levels at the moment.
Like when it dies, it's not going to
it's not going to pick a different
random map. It's gonna in the set of
random that it's been given. Yeah,
initially. And then the way that they
did is just every so often they resample
everything,
which I don't think should be that bad.
I mean, the initialization isn't too
slow, but I mean,
yeah, if you do it for that many maps,
maybe it's a little slow. So, I mean,
we'll see with this, right?
Okay. So, for max paralization, should I
start with doing like the 4096 or should
I just do like a thousand or 100 or, you
know, some just a number that works? Uh,
just whatever is close to the number of
cards you have at the moment. I think
it's like 512 per worker.
Oh, okay. Just get Okay, I see what you
mean. You're literally all you're doing
is just trying to make it round off to
something clean so we can actually like
do stuff with it.
Okay. Um, I will get to work on that.
Cool. Thank you. And, uh, I will be
after breakfast back here for the whole
rest of the day. So, yep. All right.
Thanks,
Spencer. Cool. So, I've got to go for
breakfast in a few here.
So to folks on Twitch and YouTube, uh I
will be back after I'm going to do a
couple last things on this, but I will
have to go in a minute. So, uh after
breakfast, I will be back for the whole
rest of the day working
on probably seeing if we can get some
really high perf demos here. Clean up a
whole bunch of stuff in Puffer Lib.
Really just get all this stuff ready for
release.
Um, all my stuff is on puffer.ai. It's
all free and open source code. If you
want to support this work for free,
start the GitHub. If you want to get
involved with development, you can join
us on Discord. You can also follow me on
X for more RL
content. But we will stay here for
another couple of minutes just to
see. Hey, Boxing.
Are you going for breakfast? Yeah, I'm
going for breakfast in a minute, but
then I'm back for the whole rest of the
day
It's a massive copy
overhead. Would you mind answering some
questions? Of course. I'm going to have
to go in a second, but uh yeah, after
breakfast, of course.
How much of it is in
here? Is it still 45%? If I do
this 44, it is literally all just in
write that function.
It's probably literally all in right
here,
right? Yep.
If I take this one line out.
megabytes. And that is for 131. So if we
do like 8.1 million
times
four that is 3 gigabytes 3.8 8 GB per
device.
So why is it that long? It's these are
like goodsized blocks too, right? This
is these are not tiny little
transfers. Well, I think what we'll do
is uh we'll check out what we'll do is
we'll look at like the difference
between the me if the memory is pinned
or not after breakfast and then we will
go from there. So, uh, yeah.